[Music]
it's great to be here in chicago
great to be in chicago
chicago home of the bears the bulls and
the all-new type 4 diabetes
congratulations you've done it
obviously one of uh chicago's nicknames
is the city of the big shoulders yeah
yeah which is uh much better than the
name they almost went with the
unconvincing [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh i like it
you know this town has changed a lot
since the last time we were here yeah
there's been a lot of big changes i'm
having a hard time calling the sears
tower willis tower
it's yeah right
[Applause]
it just feels wrong it's like calling
the olive garden and italian restaurant
you've got a lot to be proud of though
here you know the world's largest and
best preserved tyrannosaurus rex
currently resides at chicago's field
museum yeah
yeah the uh
the t-rex is so old it was found wearing
a cubs world series ring
i'm sorry
well that's good
half of you are angry now that's the way
to start a show he shouldn't have done
it
that wasn't like what he did
i live in los angeles now you will live
there as well i do i'm telling you i'm
not asking you
i know two great things happened for los
angeles last night first the la kings
won their first ever stanley cup
and second
second la discovered they have a hockey
team wow
wow that's fantastic
that's the one on the ice right yeah
yeah yeah
we had your mayor on last night a new
book coming out reveals that chicago
mayor rahm emanuel had a key role in the
killing of osama bin laden
yeah
in other words if i were you i'd pay
that parking ticket
you know what's nice uh today i went to
downtown chicago to see the giant bean
yeah
of course in nearby michigan the giant
bean refers to michael moore's prostate
i wanted to cut it but they said
backstage
the crowd will love it
[Laughter]
these people love prostate jokes
they love anything about the bean
[Laughter]
hey in local news the chicago city
council voted to allow produce sellers
to set up fruit and vegetable stands all
over the city
yeah
the uh the city council called the
pro-vegetable law of victory while
everyone else in chicago called it an
unprecedented attack on our lifestyle